er stirbt er steht deshalb nicht
verlassen ich da
hallo mein name ist luca und es sind 40
grad
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge der minecraft heute hier 17 heute
sind die video days das witzige ist
allerdings gab ich das video aufnehmen
ist gerade der sechzehnte weil ich
gerade für zwei drei wochen vor
produzieren wenn das heißt wenn das
video gerade wirklich sehr absitzt dann
hat alles gut geklappt und ich kann mir
selber mal ab wir fangen an mit den
commands wir geben natürlich wieder
minecraft 1 / gfp command unterstrichen
block um das essenziell notwendigste für
diese serie zu bekommen und zwar ein
command block dann habe ich mir schon
einen lämmer geholt und wir können uns
jetzt schon auf den command vorbereiten
und uns vier weitere items von und zwar
einmal ein holzschwert dann einen
cobblestone dann ein eirund in gott und
noch einen diamanten
das hat nämlich alles was mit dem
command zu tun den ich euch jetzt
vorstellen werde und zwar für mich den
command hier einfach schon mal eindrücke
hier drauf und er sieht instant eine
maschine kreiert wir bekommen keine item
sondern müssen selber wieder was tun
wo ist der diamant den ich hier
hingelegt hatte command ist von just one
kommt und zwar heiß der command gier
upgrading kommen das heißt zu deutsch
übersetzt ausrüstung aufrüsten
ausrüstungs ausrüstungs command
irgendwie so erkennt es bestimmt ihr
habt ein holzschwert und ihr denkt ich
will mich hätte aber ganz gern stein
schwert müsst ihr euch das natürlich
erstmal kräften aus dem neuen stick und
whatever
hier ist es allerdings möglich dass wir
einfach dass wurden sword neben
hinschmeißen einen kombis dondorf
schmerz mitkommen stein schwert stein
schwert hinschmeißt mit iron ingo
zusammen wir bekommen ein resort &
resort hinschmeißen mit einem diamanten
und willkommen baby bekommen ein diamant
schwert allerdings ist das noch nicht
alles und zwar können wir uns jetzt mal
zwei meter stars holen dann noch ein
weiteres diamant schwert und dann
irgendeine art fisch ich nehme es
beispielsweise man clowns fisch und
einfach zucker und dann kann man das
ganze wieder weiter verwandeln das heißt
wenn ich jetzt ein diamant schwert
bedanken
das dahinschmelzen bekommen schon
bekomme ich ein and sword magic das
gleiche mache ich normal weil es habe
ich zwei stück und wenn ich das
beispielsweise kann ich einerseits mit
einem clown fisch zusammenpacken oder
halten mit irgendeiner art fisch und
noch mal zusammen mit einem zucker und
dann bekomme ich mich zwei verschiedene
schwertern zweimal das speed sword da
gehe ich jetzt mal einfach in den game
zu null und das ganze zu zeigen und zwar
das speed ort geben teilt ganz normal
man sieht schon wenn ich das in der hand
halte wenn ich schneller wenn ich das
dann nicht mehr der hand halte bin ich
wieder langsamer beziehungsweise normal
schnell und das hält dort gibt einem
mehr leben das heißt ihr weht da schon
unten links eingeblendet da sind extra
herzen die sich jetzt gerade auffüllen
das heißt wenn ich jetzt gehe jetzt rein
theoretisch wenn die aufgefüllt sind nun
konkreter wird direkt neben mir stehen
und explodieren und ich würde dieses
schwert in der hand halten
beziehungsweise kurz vor der explosion
dahin zwischen hätte ich halt dieser
extra herzen und würde dementsprechend
nicht sterben ich glaube ich habe in den
letzten fünf monaten nicht mehr so viel
an einem stück gesagt ohne einen
einzigen katz zu setzen
ich weiß nicht ob ich mich dafür feiern
sollte oder mir eine backpfeife geben
sollte ich wusste dass ihr das sehen
wollte und das verfiel zu doll so ihr
seht jetzt schon und ich habe meine
schwerter gelöscht und ich habe hier
zwei bögen zwei retter starts ein glas
penn und ein flint und zwar wenn ich
einen bogen hinschmeißt mit einem letter
star bekomme ich ein entchen magic das
heißt kein and sword magic sondern ein
entchen bei magic und wenn ich das
gleiche normal mache bekomme ich
dementsprechend das gleiche noch mal
wenn ich das jetzt einmal mit einem glas
panel hinschmeißen und dann nochmal
einmal mit einem flint bekomme ich zwei
op bögen sag ich mal und zwar einmal
eine feier bogen da seht ihr schon der
hard power 3 pannenstreifen 5 an
breaking 2 und lud im 2 und der sniper
bogen ab auf 5 an breaking 2 ludwig 2
und - 25.500 prozent speed und das wird
jetzt mich echt interessant und zwar wir
fangen erst mal am dem fireball ich weiß
nicht ob jetzt irgendwelche mops haben
aber das ist denke ich auch erst mal
vollkommen egal weil ich das euch auch
so zeigen kann und zwar ist es halt ein
ganz normaler feier bogen so wie man ihn
schon auf einigen größeren projekten
eventuell kennt und zwar bin ich mit ihm
einfach irgendwohin schieße brennt der
feier das heißt wenn ich damit mot treff
oder so bei dem bei einem weil holz oder
so funktioniert halt nicht sondern es
funktioniert hat dementsprechend nur
beim mops die fangen dann halt anbrennen
und so weiter und so fort ich weiß nicht
ob bei tintenfischen überhaupt klappt ja
aber die sind einfach ins tor weil der
bogen so krass ist okay ich bin jetzt
einfach mal ein paar schafen damit ich
euch das anhand derer zeigen
und zwar wenn ich mit einem feuerball
halt quasi auf die darauf schließen sind
die halt einfach instant tod und man
bekommt halt gebratenes fleisch von
denen weil die halt quasi verbrennen
ich möchte nicht diese ganzen kleinen
schafe töten die tun mir so unfassbar
aber naja ich wollte euch ja auch noch
den sniper proben zeigen und zwar der
sniper bogen hat er diese - 25.000 liter
zeit wenn ich das ding in der hand halte
kann ich mich nicht mehr bewegen
ich versuche gerade nach vorne zu laufen
jetzt fragt ihr euch bestimmt erst mal
was bringt der bogen ja ganz einfach
wenn ich den bogen hand habe schaue ich
so ganz normal und wenn ich in der hand
habe
da habe ich schon mega man gesund das
heißt es ist quasi ein sniper bogen dass
ich einfach nachahmen kann und alle
ziele da hinten treffen kann
ich treffe einfach voll viele nicht weil
ich einfach schlecht bin und der ist
halt auch was ihnen instant tod und man
kann quasi besser an zielen das heißt
edward oder so wäre da beispielsweise
super geeignet
ich will euch alle gar nicht töten
möchte ich nicht weiter zeigen ja also
das ist halt das was man mit dem entchen
baum magic machen kann also einmal den
sniper bogen und halt diesen feier bogen
hier und hier nochmal den sniper bogen
wurde hat anderem und total langsam ist
finde ich auch sehr sehr cool und die
mod bzw dieser command fügt noch viel
mehr zu es gibt noch locker das doppelte
was dann zu noch hinzugefügt wird
allerdings wird das video hier den
rahmen sprengen ich bin schon in der
roda teil gerade bei 12 minuten und wer
das nachher noch unter karten das heißt
ich bin dann vielleicht im schnitt jetzt
auch fünf minuten so lange sind einzelne
komplette minecraft comments on das
heißt sie macht jetzt auch ein command
weil ich nicht gedacht hatte das ist
hier so lange dort mit dem ersten
command und ich hab ja auch mir wieder
sonst gemacht wo ich die ganze scheiße
wieder drauf geschrieben habe aber wenn
ihr euch dafür interessiert was seine
ganze noch hinzufügt könnt ihr einfach
in die beschreibung klickt euch das
video von ihm anschauen also den command
selbst testen und dann machen wir jetzt
aber erstmal weiter mit command nummer 2
roman nummer zwei es von meinem guten
alten freund etat minecraft oh ich habe
eine höhle gefunden das können wir uns
ja erst gar keine richtige höhle hat
wieder einen sehr coolen command gemacht
und zwar setzt sich einfach mal in
command login mit einem lover gebe
seinem command eindrücke auf staat und
die maschine bei optik und jetzt ist die
maschine hier schon fertig beziehen weil
sie die blöcke werden generiert und wir
sehen uns im chat jeden moment ist
maschinist fully versemmelt und wir
können noch drei teams legen dann
bekommen wir einfach ein item das bild
dungeon heißt man fragt sich erstmal
warum bild dungeon das ist der dungeon
generate command von minecraft und zwar
kann ich einfach jedes item nehmen was
normalerweise glaube ich einen squibb
spawnen würde oder so und wenn ich damit
richtig auf dem boden mache seht ihr
schon nicht werde in den gamer drei
teleportiert bisschen gewartet und es
baut sich einfach ein riesiges bauwerk
auf mit ganz vielen ebenen und es ist
quasi ein kind den dungeon creator das
heißt wenn ihr das macht habt ihr
direkten riesiges dungeon mit mega
vielen ebenen mega vielen orts- und so
weiter und jetzt sehen wir schon dann
your game what have been updated und
jeden moment werden wir zeigen nach oben
teleportiert damit wir uns das ganze
quasi von außen anschauen können
das sollte jetzt jeden moment eigentlich
hier funktionieren so jetzt sind wir
oben und zwar ist das sie gerade kreiert
worden mit diesem einen spot und wenn
wir jetzt hier beispielsweise einfach
mal runter fliegen wir können erst mal
komplett unten gehen
da seht ihr schon das geht bis zur höhe
zwei bis zum bagger fucking petrov und
hier sind überall einzelnen schlechte wo
man so reingehen kann das heißt wenn ihr
einmal beispielsweise hier rein gehe mir
eine schöne sache hier mitnehme und die
einfach mal hier hinsetzen wie die schon
diesen kisten drin mit beispielsweise
einem netto star
hier ist halt ein riesiges dungeon zu
spinnen drehen
hier sind spinnen davon dass eisen hier
vorne wieder ne kiste das auto man etwas
darin halt schon krass items am start
hier steht einfach mal sonst markt
locken hier sind ganz viele zombies er
sagt selber in seinem video das man
nicht ohne hier sind gold noch dass man
nicht ohne komplette diamant rüstung
herunter gehen sollte und ich denke das
kann man auch schon verstehen warum
stimmt auf jeden fall mega krass dass
dieser command einfach so ein riesiges
dungeon hier hinzufügt und man kann
einfach hier durchlaufen und sich alles
mögliche anschauen und sich verlaufen so
wie ich das gerade dachte arbeitet ist
mal gut gegangen und jetzt könnt ihr
beispielsweise auch mal einen dungeon
hier oben gehen das jetzt glaube ich
dass höchste dungeon das sollte halt
dementsprechend dann noch nicht so krass
schwer sein ist aber sehr zugewuchert
definitiv alter okay das ist das erste
mal dass ich meine doch die ganz weiter
zu optimieren nachdem ich diese eine
krasse minecraft sechs vogler
er stirbt er stirbt des firefox steht
nein ich glaube dass sie sterben lassen
sich da
st
könnt ihr euch noch an diese krasse
fakes folge damals erinnern wo ich
einfach zwei spyder jobs gesehen haben
bzw exporte aber direkt untereinander
das war so krass ey gold 1 übrigens
nicht fragen ja so viele was mit dem
microsoft excel
es ist einfach so dass alle mir werden
hat immer noch so viel effekt zugesendet
allerdings nehme ich jeden tag der mir
zugesendet wird der irgendwie eventuell
schon mal vorgestellt wurde oder halt
noch nie irgendwo gezeigt wurde
suche ich mir raus und packe die in das
buch was sich derzeit schreibe über
minecraft und über command und über main
kanal und pvp strategien und da stehen
unter anderem auch pvp strategien von
krankhafter sturm waffe komme und so
weiter drin weil wales sage jetzt mal
ganz kurz die am ende der folge ich war
halt einfach so dass wir uns bei dem
buch arbeiten gedacht hatten
okay wir wollen unbedingt zum pvp
strategien reiter machen weil wieder
super ideen fürs design hatten und dann
habe ich mir einfach gedacht so ich kann
aber kein minecraft pvp aber wie wäre es
da wenn ich einfach wieder anders fragen
würde daher das eigentliche idee habe
ich in dieser woche gefragt steht die
hab ich noch gefragt kommen habe ich
noch gefragt gerade ihr euch noch
gefragt und wir noch ganz viele andere
youtuber drin wir haben skins von
anderen youtuber anbrennen und zwar
sofort also das wird quasi und
kooperations passt scho also der
hauptteil ist natürlich über mein kraft
und der rest ist über mich und ein paar
seiten sind aber echt auch mit anderen
usern voll also keine ahnung wieso ich
jetzt wie nicht auf das buch gekommen
überhaupt was soja über die minecraft
facts und zwar die minecraft ex kommen
wahrscheinlich nach dem buch wieder
irgendwann aber derzeit wird mich quasi
die kompletten facts die ich habe
einfach nur dem buch und will wieder
einpacken und dass das muss so gut wie
möglich wird und dann nicht nur noch 15
dinge auf den markt bringe aber ich
würde sagen dass war schon kommen zwei
und dementsprechend war es auch mit
dieser folge welchen da drohte schon bei
25 minuten bin ich wert das nach jetzt
so krass runter schneiden müssen wenn es
euch trotzdem gefallen aber will ich
mich über eine klitzekleine bewertung
freuen das zeigt mir dass solche
gefallen hat dass ihr microsoft commerce
wollt ich glaube ich lege mich jetzt in
der badewanne voll mit eiswürfeln